hey how's it going the other day I was
driving in my vehicle and this song came
on and I instantly had this just
reaction of just wanting to dance
there's so many songs out there that
probably do the same thing for you guys
I don't know what a lot about this
reading song I ain't no one was well I
just wanna dance who is this who is this
oh my god yeah I just am so pull into
some back alley okay
Shazam download he finally be here oh
the song is called I'm like yes this is
my jam then I don't look they got in my
car and I started freaking just going
nuts I mean just dancing in the street
things no car it's a note on my car
but I want to be like what is that song
for you that makes you just wanna
subscribe and make sure you follow me
all over the Internet as I just seen
that's all face time to go dance oh my
god this is my junior team at school
so I'm outside now because I attempted
to start shooting this video in my hotel
room but it was so dark and it's also
rumored to be haunted